in uh
aido
Kona you have the inward
spiral and then it's revers is your
outward
spiral although commonly done but not
correct you have
these um movements where you go in and
out horizontally
and then movements where you go up and
down and sometimes they try to get on
the center line so like for example the
up and down one you'll see people get to
a biomechanical efficiency you bring the
elbows in you're going to get more
leverage and then this hand goes like
this
okay uh you see that stuff in the iwama
where you're always trying to overpower
someone or um mamoto he does that all
the time cha Sensei did that all the
time shabata Sensei and it's clearly
you're trying to overpower someone by
using um more leverage against the
person okay so an example of
that uh let's say he does m so two hands
okay and then you know because you're
trying to feel powerful and make
yourself powerful you make him stay
still don't push in and stay in place
squeeze as hard as you can maybe even
lower your Center you know so he's here
like that and you're like oh oh I I and
then so then you'll see people will come
in you see and then they kind
of overpower him you
see to do the
technique okay make sense okay okay but
that's not iido because I shouldn't be
trying to overpower somebody okay that's
just ego tripartite mind will the power
and the fear cycle of behavior
okay um because it's still just a force
engine you see so if he comes over
here and uh I grab him and he's going to
try to Anchor his
elbow and do that same leverage I let
try just try the
shape yep okay
so he can't get the engine there he
could move towards it no no
no you see now it's closer to his Center
and now you try it I'll let you try it
again so he moves good bring your elbow
in when you do it try again little slow
down I'm not going to resist the first
one
step bring your elbow to your Center and
then okay I'm not going to resist step
elbow to your Center there you go okay
so we do it
again it's not going to happen okay cuz
it's just an engine trying to outow
another
engine okay um some of the things you
notice
though because people are attracted to
it because we love the delusion of outp
powering someone and then everything
will be okay if we could only outow
people um but some of the things you
notice is um I'm just standing there
waiting there's no
kazushi at all at contact he's got to
wait until I get out power do you see so
um
that's weird uh there's no energy really
going on uh in other words from the
Marshall perspective which this tends to
be and people tend to think it is I'm
he's really trying he's not
choreographed he's not soft it's a
really strong
grab what's he really doing
martially we're just staming there
so again he grabbed really hard you
see nothing's going to happen I just
neutralized
everything it's not till he tries
something
else that something happens do you do
you get it in other words if we're just
here and I just squeeze
him is he's not being assaulted do you
see he kind of checked my weight but now
it's just squeezing at this
point you see it's stupid okay it
doesn't make martial
sense also being grabbed doesn't make
martial sense you
shouldn't you shouldn't feel martially
accomplished because you can get a
leverage
going because the Marshall question is
never let the guy grab you you shouldn't
be where he could grab so it's not a
marshal question it's just the ego
tripartite mind satisfa
it's not
iido um so let's go into these
Spirals and look at
them a little more closely from the
three components okay really the first
component the physical component and
then the second component the energetic
component
so
what we're going to
see at the physical
component is actually a superior Force
engine than that last one Al although it
can be strong it's really not that
strong in comparison okay um it uses
small muscle groups usually the biceps
and the deltoids those these are
terrible muscles to use in combat okay
and then we'll ALS also see
that um the lack of kazushi comes from
the fact that it usually only travels
through one or two Dimensions that other
hand workk whereas the spirals will
travel through three dimensions and
that's how you get the center moving and
things like that okay so if I have a
basketball and you look at these lines
that are going across if I'm moving my
arms like this and pay attention to the
like the equator line here okay it just
stays where it
is
okay but if I do the inward spiral
you'll see that the equator line started
to go forward you see okay so we're
here and uh let's say for
example I get to e you see and a lot of
people think that this
goes like this you see and nothing
happened to his body so that would be
similar
to I'm here and I just move it move it
that way nothing happens to the equator
line
so so but if I do
the the hour spiral which isn't just my
hand and my elbow staying in the same
concentric Circle and moving out at my
shoulder but my elbow coming in you see
and you'll you'll feel the difference so
here nothing happens to
you I do the hour spiral and you'll
see his Center gets touched gets moved
okay obviously on the inward spiral you
can see that his Center gets
moved as opposed to I'm just make this
circle see so here's here's my
circle
a
spiral and he has a lot of pressure on
your shoulder don't you
okay no movement on the
center
see so and that's because it's traveling
in three
dimensions if you come
here and i'lljust the mechanical
weakness of it well you're going to have
to learn how to do this cuz you don't
noce you kind of just swing your arm in
a
circle and you catch it okay just try a
couple there you go and right here is
the weak point because of this Reliance
on the inner deltoid he's never going to
get there are you
try you see that and so he's trying to
go ahead he's trying the old the other
leverage get your elbow closer to your
body and try to do this
is or some people stay out there and
then they reach
across go
ahead and again he'll you see the outer
deltoid here you're never going to get
there already
try maybe try to drop he has to do the
other leverage stuff but then again look
at my
Center you
see nothing's happening to me because
he's on just a two-dimensional plane at
best
okay um
energetically if this
is in in
iido correct iido it follows the Silk
Road mudra theories okay Chris come so
you can
see and it's different from Modern iido
because modern iido looks at things
mechanically superficially materially
and so they at best get biomechanics
going and so um they will feel Superior
leverage by having things attached to
your Center Line because obviously the
more peripheral you are to the center
line the more deltoid and I already said
that's a weak muscle group to use so
they'll try to come near the center line
just as I've described in the previous
technique and that does bring some
biomechanical soundness to it
um but
energetically um it's denying a bunch of
stuff from Silk Road culture so in Silk
Road
culture uh it's not that I move my
Center to move my
hands I move my hands to move my Center
is the proper way okay and it goes back
to the mudra Theory okay
so uh and I'll do this this kind of in
Reverse
fashion so I have my lower
tanden and I use hand gestures to
move the Yang and Yin that constitute
the lower ton dent I don't I don't move
my body to move my hands okay it's
reverse and so if you are and what
you're trying to do with the yangong and
Yin in your lower tonen is spiral rotate
them now add to that that my hands move
my lower ton Den therefore my hands must
spiral rotate therefore they must travel
through the three dimensions and not one
dimension okay making for
example this
technique here's your ball and nothing
really happen happens to the wall okay
versus I want
elevation then my hands have to move in
an inward spiral that goes up and that's
where we're going to go
okay to start though you have to know
how to form
Lon
so I'm going to try to describe it to
you and my
best um upic
advice is that you just use these tips
to get in the ballpark and then you just
struggle and struggle and struggle until
you feel something outside of your
intention okay because your intention is
getting in the way so some of the things
will start with what it's not it's not a
dead hand it's not it's not
relaxed and you're now a wet noodle it's
not that it's also not this what people
have come to mean as iido that's not it
either
okay um it's not finger tension and it's
not forearm tension so think about that
there's there shouldn't be tension in
your forearm which there always is if
you do
that yoshinon iido hand there's tension
in the form you can see it okay so don't
flex this don't try to flex your fingers
because you'll
you'll also Flex that forearm to do that
okay what I would like you to do is
instead uh expand the bones in your
hand what happens to your fingers and
what happens to your forarm is
irrelevant so I expand the bones in my
hand until I start feeling the fingers
flex and the forearm Flex don't go past
that okay so try try this I expand the
metacarpal these bones until I feel the
forearm FL too much
okay so I I have some parameters like
too little not expanding the
metacarpal tension tension too much
okay then the next upaya tip I would
like to give you is if you're doing this
right there'll be a hollow oness in
here like you could put water in there
it would hold there but I don't want to
shape it do you
see that's what a lot of people make
that mistake they're like oh it's like a
a cup well no because you're now you're
metacarpal are not
expanding do you guys get it okay so I
have to expand the metacarpal these
bones through the
hand without tension here without
tension
here and I should have a cup shape
okay the next thing I would like for you
to that's where you should struggle like
get that shape first okay
some things that can start to happen
that you'll sense is there's like a
charge that runs down the middle
finger along the
sides I don't want to describe it past
that okay and you'll have some
sense uh of expansion and
extension through that middle
finger
okay this
way it does something to your other hand
your other finger particularly your
index finger which is also not well
understood and but I I don't want to
make more of it because I don't I don't
want you to cosmetically Chase it but
when you feel them charge in the middle
finger you'll see that it comes out of
alignment with the index finger which
iido people don't do they always make
their
hands like that but but no they're not
they're not in
alignment do you guys see that so don't
feel that you have to keep your your
fingers all the same they're not all the
same particularly that middle finger as
it's related to the index finger
okay the next thing I'd like you to do
and you can do this on your own
time is after you have the
shape you can start to
press that those that
Center Cup against the other Center cup
let me try it
now
okay and you kind of open and close and
you have to keep the shape you got to
watch that you're not curling your
fingers closed okay keep the
shape drop all your shoulders sit in
sesa drop all your shoulders
do your seated drill
One release all tension straighten your
head it's drill one of the C you and II
said so you can feel
them almost pushing on each
other you can pull apart you don't feel
it and you after you get good at it you
you can feel it from pretty far
away and all we're learning
here is how to activate L
go
you can coordinate it with your
breath but you don't need
to so that
activated aspect
is what you do in your inward spiral and
your outward spiral you never let it go
dead doesn't go dead
okay all right let's get to the shapes
now as there's only two
Spirals and there's three levels jodon
Chon and
gon those three levels are is
different points in either of the two
spirals okay so for example if I want to
go to the lower level of gon I don't
pull my hand down like this I'm in one
dimension okay is it is there a way of
getting leverage yeah yes but it's
mechanical leverage again so if he is
stronger than mean he's lifting up I
can't get that you'll try your tricks
you know to get down there but again his
Center is not moving okay and more
importantly my Center is not moving
okay so to get to the lower
level you are going to start the outward
spiral the water spiral
okay and he'll feel a couple things so
for example you can't push cuz it's
pressing on his Center okay
um if he and once I start it let's say
he's pulling now do you see you're going
to change the angle of his pull so at
the physical component you're going to
change the angle of this pull so if you
look his elbow is trying to go back this
way and you're going to turn his elbow
out of position you see as you drop
it so laong home and you can see his
Center gets turned and moved okay it's
not me
going in a
circle it's not
me
[Music]
leveraging
here I turn my tanden with my hand shape
Bo moves his whole
body again leverage you see he's just
standing
still till the very end start move move
his whole
body okay let's try that
Dr while the hand moves the lower tonden
field
what modern iido think of your Center
this biomechanical point in your body
that is moved by the
qua so my hand my quaw doesn't stay here
and then I try to do this shape because
I can't get over there if I turn my qua
you can see how much more I can move
that
okay also we already talked about as the
qua releases on one side and presses
through on the other side so too does
this shoulder of that same side so when
I'm here like this it'll release the qua
but leave my shoulder
here uh you get all twisted
up so here in this case he's pushing in
the last case he was pulling um you you
will release you see you release you
move in and then you move back
okay uh so remember to do that don't
keep your quad still don't keep your
shoulders
locked um this spiral is going back to
the energetics and doing and doing what
I'm doing on the tonden field I'm
turning it scooping it and then over the
top moving it this way I think you guys
are picturing cuz their head is here and
you're like just moving now in a
circle okay so I'm going to just to stay
with the ball I'm going to change the
shape of my arm so don't freak out okay
so here's the qual yield and the
shoulder
yield right I'm going to come under back
this way you see I'm going to come over
the top this way and then I'm moving it
this way this is what I'm
doing over the top it's the inside of
the arm because of where La gong is
facing that's moving the top it's not
the outside of my arm and I just knock
him over
okay so you'll look for those things now
okay and we can have them pushing again
so he's pushing them okay so
for
pull this
way
don't go here and here's that Circle
your outer deltoid is going to be here
okay
no spin it picture here forget him
picture What's Happening Here imagine
that basketball here it's inside my body
you can see me scooping
it drawing it on this
top you can see the middle finger on the
on the L
gong okay and he becomes irrelevant like
he feels like nothing but my mind's not
even on him or anything but I'm feeling
all of this stuff okay let's try it
again okay so uh again if you have
someone stronger than you the The
Leverage stuff is not going to work okay
so we have two
people and you're gripping and you're
gripping and they're holding me this is
going to be very hard to do you see and
also nothing's nothing's moving them
okay what what I'm going to do
instead is move my lower T end field the
same exact way there's the qua yield and
the shoulder yield boom move it
move
it I'll hold more lost ground
Vector you can see how hard they're
pushing as I didn't even hold ground
Vector on the first one okay so Bo move
it move my
[Music]
tanden and it it's it's not a marshal
feed I'm not trying to do a marshal Feet
Again a marshall feed I wouldn't be S I
wouldn't be sitting and say I won't let
you grab
me it's more of
a a Temptation you're like whoa whoa let
me let me try some leverage stuff
instead no don't move your T in L
gong
you can feel how
[Music]
relaxed
okay totally impossible with the other
leverage engine not not even close to
being possible but here doesn't really
change anything
okay
um here we go try okay so in the
technique it started out at gon but
obviously we came
up and in order to come up you have to
pass through the other aspects of the
spirals okay so if you pay
attention when when you came around
here you have to now rotate this back
towards
yourself and in in there's
Chon
okay um keep your grip so that you could
see what effect it has on his body so so
I'm going here and if I go full chew
on you can see that his Center is moving
it opens up the back
more so static
now here's get
on we know that Chon ends like this but
in this system
gon proceeds
Cheon okay always you don't just turn
your wrist and go like
that no so I'm going to go chew on or
get on into the chew on and there's the
opening to the
[Music]
outside get
done shoot
on yield get on shoot
on and you can see how it keeps him
moving we don't go get on Enter he
didn't
move get on shoot two
do get on shoot
on a lot of people do this like
this that's that vertical
plane but I'm
turning
my Tom Den
deel with my
mudra try it and to get to jodon I don't
have
another I don't have that so to get to
jodon you're going to see that I'm going
to first pass vedon Pastor Chon and then
Chon will push
up okay so I change my you have to look
down at me and my inward
spiral is this way
okay so I'll pass through all of these
things keep your
grip We'll add the other
hand
okay
he's pushing push push push he's
pushing if you make it too big you're
going to be in the other places what
what's making it big what you did with
your quadw and shoulder so for this one
I do very very little with my quad and
shoulder okay this is a little yield
here and
then this is
different scooping reeling his body
in he pushing pushing
pushing
obviously he's
pushing and your techniques are
here but we're just going to
work turn the tan you you can push your
strong I
push
turn
rotate keeps rotating
up it's
pushing
rotate I'm
underneath I'm on the
front I'm on the inside
now a lot of
[Music]
people are so used
to this
thing you
think like
this but this is is incorrect my elbow's
not out there
okay he's
pushing Bo boom boom so if camera comes
over
here his grip is on the center of my
head if I move
my hand to the center of my head then
the weight is on the side of my
body can you see that okay you put the
weight on top of your
head he's pushing
again Bo
Bo and now take note of where that elbow
is so my face is here I'm not here like
this and over like this in this weird
posture okay
pushing now I'm turning my T
Den so we could do hiji Naga
there
okay it's right
here tap that
El pushing
pushing
go
slow
turning
turning okay
try okay so my people here are having
that that problem there a lot of you
know I think it goes back to this idea
is it's ego tripartite
mind um leverage hand
upstead of what I'm saying is I only
have two Tachi it's really one okay the
inward spiral the outward spiral I gave
all the anatomical reasons for it I gave
the energetic reasons for it so but even
my people here are having problems like
why should I do trudon and not go from
gon to jodon okay well when I go
here and you want to go I'm supposed to
go up here and you can see that second
part is just the leverage part
okay so he's
pushing and I go here and just to show
the mistake I go here and there's not
really any action on his Tom den and
there's no action on
mine what I'm saying is I'm going to do
gon and then the
Chon and that pushes up then here's the
elbow exposure for
henia Bo you could look at his body I'm
going to get more do you
see
Home El go
down if he tries to resist me here
trying to go up I can't go up because I
don't really have a superior leverage
except to work my way out of his fingers
at best if he's strong enough if there's
enough friction I can't even do
that instead I'm turning my Center
oh when you you do a strong enough
Chon a lot of times you don't I would
say probably all the time you don't
actually lift the Hound he ends up
lifting the Hound okay so if you pay
attention you see his hand is lifting
it not me trying to lift my
hand as as his balance goes give little
energy okay lot of energy give a lot of
energy okay all right so as I come
around that energy is being weighted by
the gon and as I go to the Chon Chon it
picks it up do you
see so again lots of energy okay right
now I'm on top of that energy so I'm
going to get out of the way of it with
the chew on it comes up on its
own
that's different don't get the same
kazushi don't get the same angle
cancellation here
and he's not even falling that way
energy iner is not going that way so
lots of energy this thing goes here
boom okay